ah oh sorry God that was a weird way I
start my Monday yeah it's fun for the
listeners right clears throat - no maybe
I wasn't maybe I was just expressing
kind of like a guttural you know primal
you know feeling well the Punisher does
that on Netflix he does huh yeah I kind
of dig in I kind of do yeah and then I'm
on the new series right now the Punisher
season two's out on Netflix amazing
amazing and the first one was my
favorite comic book series yet but he
gets arrested and they have them in a
mug shot well the actor that plays him
is not six three or 64 in the mug shot
they haven't said no really goes boom
you JYJ goes he's not that tall to do it
no I assume isn't in person of every
care five nine yeah about that actors
are not five eight five nine I'm a stud
he's a stud when I once said I'm I'm
taller than most actors I work with
really yes
how about Stevie blue eyes was talking
about his arms and then my friend clop
came in on it what we see about arms you
like arms I'll bigger collapse on clop
and and by the way he's quote-unquote
skinny right now at 2:45
I'm skinny right now but 245 jacked yeah
you'll see him if ya Klopas digit jack
he's jacked
well his arms look like thighs yeah he's
ridiculous but what actually is more
impressive to me as his ass and legs
that's more impressive here's a long
flat ass though you don't have a bubble
he has a bubble Bob he'll be his arms
like the comments are hilarious because
they go hey who's mr. picograms on the
right he's not though no he's not doing
steroids he's just a giant man yep he's
such a freak like I remember seeing him
he was eating ice cream when you guys
were walking down the boardwalk in
Venice he had a shirt off he was every
bit of six foot six and probably 255 260
cuz he was lifting back then and he
looks like a [ __ ] superhero shredded
yet it's so weird they said an eight
pack he looks like a real like real Thor
like yeah he looks like a real Torian
bigger than and this is why I don't
assume everybody's on steroids in life
because they're him and Tim Tebow
right I've been
I've known since Papua yeah football
they're both freaks streak and he's a
bigger freak than Tebow in physically
yes it's like just yeah I six five six
six six every bit of it yeah he's ever
been a six six we lose always always
like you can eat banana splits he cake
every day well he sexy it's bigger and
more shredded I don't know what's going
on that's some weird Viking genetics
like that's a true Viking that's like a
weird like he's like one of those
strongmen and he has to he has two
daughters yeah they're both big they're
gonna be big hey girls big girls don't
come don't come light in the ass when
they hit 18 don't come in the I said
don't come light in the ass don't come
don't step light in the ass in other
words don't come to that game if you're
light in the ass you have to have some
power that's what I meant
clap that's Brian no Bob I want to sound
record Brian no I did not I said you
can't come to that arena if you're light
and the ass is what I'm in sir Chris
Hansen one other thing you know you want
a girl who's built a woman is built
don't come in here certainly and she's
strong don't got a minute you're too
light in the ass for that so you can
take your mind a little cutter no you
[ __ ] up no you [ __ ] up in there no
don't say that
god you're a terrible person dude there
look at him there though look at him
there's Joe that's look at that look at
all that's when I first walked in that's
when I first walked in and I'm [ __ ]
doing my shtick and you guys are just
looking at me in Klopp with his bemused
detachment there's another girl rodent
with this chin down kind of looking at
me in a suspicious way wondering where
I'm going with this
go back chin I think there's another
that one's good oh you're yawning there
though Brian [ __ ] or maybe I'm going Wow
no you're you're singing I'm going
ring look at that thing goes like I
almost so looks like a cab driver from
the cockney England now goats oh look at
those look at those three gentlemen
there and I do have a gold Saint Laurent
coat on
that'll be okay now go to the picture
Brian just posted once you show what
father time does the please father time
does then he's been he's been like you
that picked painting guns Bri I know I
messed up now let's talk about and
father times been nice to you even nice
to me before I had it so nice to you
have tied symmetrical face back then
dude look at you two look at our jaw
lines look at Joe's shirt by the way
that's a shiny shirt dude see he think I
like how he tries to play down that he
doesn't have fashion he's a good-looking
guy they're too good both you guys are
good-looking there we we we I bet you
guys laid the Hammers down we did what
hammers I mean [ __ ] everybody we did
well
I bet look at you didn't go out and not
get you know female attention I'll be
honest your there's some fine dolls
there yeah a jaw lines are amazing well
couple cuties and we were funny to row
get home on Rogen is wearing a dope
vintage moto moto bikers jacket leather
that's Nigeria now which I owned yeah
and then he has a shiny sheer almost
reptile print its metallic it's it's
like it's like chain metal its chain
mail it looks good yeah like like a
sword wouldn't go through that you
understand the look at you to young
whippersnapper
couple your home doing that you know
it's great when you make this post don't
put the date at all just let people
assume oh yeah that was probably
literally that was I'll tell you when I
was I think that was 1997
maybe 98 but probably nicely set up in
my ass that looks like 88 bro that's not
97 that was no I didn't mean him till
so 95 96 97 that's 97 yeah that might be
between Matt so it might be 1996 you can
see it in there it's in there on the
pitch Oh 98 though it says yeah Wow
you go dude that's 20 years 1998 20
years ago 20 [ __ ] years ago
Wow look what 21 years does to your face
we [ __ ] I in my in my mind I still
look like that guy oh really
yeah in my mind bro do you like looking
at me like I'm a museum piece
no I'm just saying all right that's cool
man yeah everyone looks different though
don't they even though that's what
happens you get older and you just have
to accept that you're okay what cute
nose back then look at that [ __ ] your
nose well you know has grown a little
bit yeah it's grown Rogan was a Grodin
was a dime behind it looks like a poor
male points does he's an Italian porn
star right there look at that I bet you
Giovanni hot smoke right there man just
some killers dude yeah cat would have
you always look like this like you look
yes literally always looked just like
this just a slightly older version yeah
that's agent age is so interesting ages
have age in Asians
why make cats boyfriend this weekend oh
he came to the special oh really that's
cool I don't 6:7 black dude is that
right yeah I trade it up that's amazing
I just six foot seven black man mm-hmm
congratulations no one to match with my
sister six foot seven and by the way
muscular broad yes of course flick I
mean find space I mean that's a lot of
man yeah do you need a shock in a ladder
to keep track of where you are no I'm a
power lifter oh so you're not afraid at
all you step right up to it yeah
just kidding Brian I met damn it it
about her same size you got me all
excited no same size yeah very nice guy
got piss I know that's why I did it I
without it excited me too ah damn it
know if he was towering over you yeah
hey bro your jaw bro
yeah hey this is a men aid I know so hey
Doug what's up dawg yeah hey called care
dog my friend who I did a movie
with I said hi done she was sneaking
into the hotels like what's wrong with
you guys nothing
my oh well real no it's a girl I knew I
did movie with I where were you she was
I was on a date don't tell anybody you
go with who and she goes I went on a
date with Shaq once and I was like do
tell it's gonna do Angwin I'm like
whatever but he's a fun guy great guy
he's a [ __ ] great man his tiny dick
that's what I wanted to know I know she
didn't get that do you still have her
number
she's well-known did you still have her
number yeah texture dude let's find out
about the dick how many years ago was
that oh wow uh no it's like four or five
six I know enough time we should tell us
see I'm always nervous that I'm I don't
even like sanics I don't know if Shaq
was married or is me I don't know I
think it's bro science four or five
seventeen years yeah whatever it was it
was when he was single yeah either way
though Tex well after we get okay I'm
fine now Oh that'd be cool man mmm
we're the fun weekend dude right proud
of you I'm very proud of you you did a
great job and you're special amazing
crowd they were so fun yeah me and Joe
Rogan open for Brandon you're awesome
brothers they're Jason his buddy Klopp
was there we had we had the crew out
Steve you owe us TV blue eyes was there
you a Showtime crew when when toshow
tongue crew when we when when when
Brendan was out announced bye bye Joe
and we did a little huggy hug and he
pounded everybody and he goes right
before he runs out he goes I go hey I
look at him he was hard not to cry I
said that yeah yeah that was hard not to
cry I thought you're gonna start crying
when you went out there huh when they
give me when they all stood up and he
stopped sit down like you got to sit
down I do not want to start this show
like this man it's emotional my god
because it's like you've been you did a
hundred and thirty four shows to that
point
I mean and so then you went out there
and it's like it's like it's a lot of
work man and if you guys will see the
the set it's a really cool set and his
name is spelled in the background in
giant letters like letters that are
probably
the hollywood's eight feet literally you
could see yeah i mean little small on
the hollywood sign like eight nine feet
high here and one of the guys looks at
brandon and says do you want the letters
you can keep them Brennan was like no
because I wouldn't know what to do with
them well what i doing is you put them
in your backyard we really will know
that be the biggest tool move of all
time also how would i get him there sir
yes do i don't know do you want him or
not
uh no no the best was that your brother
yeah so Brennan's brother Jay and his
buddy Jason went to Japan Jason the
biggest Filipino man in the world whose
head is always sweating went to a Muay
Thai camp in Thailand he's in a picture
Jay posted yep and I go and I go how was
scale of one to ten how was your trip to
Japan and before I can get you pan out I
get this ten eleven with the ten it was
eleven so I'm like well at eleven
well what Duke's do explain tell me
about it
and he goes okay so we went shopping and
then we went to eat at these places and
then we went to this building that was
really tall physically am I wrong then
he goes and then then we met this black
guy named black Terry and black Terry
taught Michael Jackson how to dance
I went line it goes that's a lie and he
goes no he did he told him I go the
black Terry guy in Japan didn't teach
Michael Jackson had a [ __ ] myth that
was that was the that was literally all
I got out of him about Japan that was it
Wow nothing made a black guy named black
Terry I told Jason went dude I've heard
the rumors around there I'll CJ's
married so he's out but for Jason
dude there's [ __ ] bars there have you
heard about this of course I am
businessman sit down and girls are
underneath the table sucking you off
while you're negotiating business with
your boys right so I'm like dude I don't
think that's a very good deal I think
what we need to do next what we need to
do that's how it goes there yes she does
yes it does
I said did you visit one of those
oh no no he went shopping shopping well
you guys can't be my friend anymore
meanwhile Jessie J wearing a [ __ ]
judo a denim judo than that picture it
saggy top I should wear in jujitsu and I
go what does that mean I go that's
expensive right he goes yeah it's a
hashimoto or whatever the [ __ ] it is
Japan get him it had like a tie heavy I
was like guards if you won't shut up
about Japan then you know he's fashion
more than you do it yeah he knows more
about two and when we were driving back
he goes hey let's stop at this Japanese
bar they have great something I go no
well no will you get over it you're
driving me nuts man god you're on this
Japanese kick get the [ __ ] over yeah
he's one of these Japanese New Balances
and these jeans
he said Waring's double RL double RL f
Lauren he sent me these uh these jeans
from Japan that I forget what they call
blue something but they're the best
denim comes from Japan and they deep dye
him something he goes show do you know
what to do with these he gets my house
this is it yes do you know what to do
with these are you no no they're a
little big yes that's that's how they're
supposed to be I swear to god he's dead
serious
yes so what you do you put them on you
put them on and because you wanted to
fit tight you want to fit perfect and
have like that selvage look you're
wearing them into the ocean so just put
them on go into the ocean and just kind
of swim maybe do some squats and I went
are you [ __ ] me right now he goes no
that's for the best fit on it well
that's never happened I'm not going to
ever he goes do you want the best fit or
not you'll if that's what it takes no
I'm not yours alright well let's just
fill up your bathtub with salt water it
no we're not doing that I don't want
some weird would you wash them
afterwards yes so you this salt doesn't
fit yeah and the salt and uh whatever
just you want like that that grind is so
interesting all jeans start off like
this dark yeah and then they go light
these are darker than those what about
dart dart where I'm in the ocean you
just want to roll around the sand and
get it all kind of into it well I'm not
that's not
I'm never know you know that'd be a
nightmare getting back to the house
what are you doing today I got a I got a
thing I got to do I have to go to the
Tesla dealership and then I got to go
wear jeans into the ocean and roll
around the sand so I get the
perfect forget you have your like jumped
up pulling jeans or anything they get no
they get heavy so heavy
no you're drown oh wait around yeah yeah
drag you under great jeans I think they
learn that Japanese denim is thick about
as thick as elephant skin oh they make
the best day walk through a thorn bush
with no problem then there's there's so
there's clop there's Jason to the far
right obviously my brother at shark eyes
don't smile on the middle grant I'll go
so with off whites yeah fly out feeling
good man he likes his watches too oh
yeah Todd Feldman your boy our boy Todd
Feldman one of the great people for a
lot of reasons but an amazing super
agent at sea a super agent we're in the
Daytona a time of the roller state he's
so so yeah Todd makes some money
Todd's what would you call very
successful like Todd Phillips who wrote
directed The Hangover swears by DVD yeah
he's the man he's a man when it comes to
Game of Thrones huge never heard I'm a
huge agent and a [ __ ] great guy but
anyway he he's wearing his Daytona and
and j-just looks at it and just all he
does is he's looking at it and he just
extends his pointer finger he just
extends it and kind of jobs it at the
watch he says and Todd looks at it and
Jay looks at it in Todd goes just not
yeah that expensive watch yeah yeah yeah
yeah what's that what do I run you this
is the vintage one rolls across Rolex 40
grand Japan which really yeah right 40
grand okay all right it's very it's the
white face Daytona vintage one it's
called it's the gold rose gold so you
see the brand-new it's 22 great so his
is even more than that is the rose gold
one so yeah there you go forward brand
new is 40 grand but his is vintage so is
it even more rare Wow
yeah I know that yeah Wow treat him your
Tesla for that yeah do that
I'm not doing that and I Tesla's room I
want to get around bro hey let me keep
your car I'll get my new Tesla - how
about this you know take a delete powder
what am i you know I talked to Todd
every day you do I have a few close
friends in LA you Rogen
Taliah who I talked to
every day you wrote in daliyah and then
feldman every day he's such a good I
understand I understand they they drop
my test loft the new one yeah it was
great because this guy Anthony who is a
fan of the podcast and works at Tesla
and he goes they had they kind of [ __ ]
up delivery and he said I'm talking to
him I go well I gotta get I gotta get it
before 1:00 and he goes I know I don't
want job and Rogan mad at you I know
shops gotta shoot a special and I go get
the [ __ ] out of here
you know this meanwhile they drop off my
Tesla and there was a little glitch in
the paperwork and I looked at what's my
monthly payment I was like well that
doesn't work so I go you're gonna have
to take this back now until we figure it
out which they did they do did you lease
them right yeah at least it smart yeah
are you getting the same one just newer
black midnight silver black black on
black glass roof now my autopilot my
autopilot now I'll be driving first of
all I can just hit a button and it's
just dumb parallel park a few people
died or whatever no no this autopilot is
different I'll be driving my autopilot
and it'll switch lanes it does
everything it's got way more cameras
it's crazy but also now in about three
months I think they're gonna have what's
called the Mad Max download which is my
Tesla will communicate with all the
other Tesla's on the road and create
like this em Wed this net of information
where so I'll be micro be driving itself
and it'll it'll go hey there's an
accident
Tesla's picking up an accident three
miles down the road and we're gonna slow
down so that's the future of of driving
you mean ways yeah yeah but it's a
personal ways that that's better than
ways well for sure in my mind yeah cuz
it's tested shut up Brandon no we'll be
cool I would like my car to drive itself
sometimes yeah especially in traffic oh
my god dude that Burbank up Friday I
want to get out and um I ran my face
into the other cards oh and then and and
by the way you coming down to San Diego
on a Friday
Joe was fine we didn't get much Saturday
we got there no we got oh yeah we did
front yeah Friday nightmare Saturday
night we got a two and a half on the way
back to now
yeah we're fine I'm thinking about next
week just cuz I'm impressed my son he's
so obsessed with trucks and I do need
another car just for driver I'm gonna
get a raptor you know what that is
for raptor yeah it's a truck yeah my
son's gonna go crazy over it you're
getting a raptor yeah you need another
car anyway cuz you drive that I what I'm
admire about you as you drive that
impossible Porsche I'm not you're not
you're only car everyday like nobody
does that you're like now I'm gonna
drive this car I'm not driving in the
ground it's made to be driven man yeah
but you don't find it tiring it's a lot
of work but you just drive it I love it
I love is that a stick my Porsche no
they don't make the RS and stick they
don't know Rogen's is they older ones
they do well I don't they I thought
stick was because now electronics no one
wants stick in the end and like true
race car guys do but then what's faster
is PDK uh-uh
automatic no it beats all the race you
have the trip tonic shifters never use
it never know what are you yeah just try
the car yeah let me get that rapture so
my son thinks I'm a spider-man now do
guys do do people say [ __ ] to you as
you're driving around that that
ridiculous purple no they don't say you
don't did people die me they look at it
people take pictures of it but no I like
don't know did I ask you quit nobody
asked your questions and I mean real car
get Porsche at me and Porsche as we do
this do you know do you guys give each
other thumbs upses oh you don't know the
Tesla sign so on Porsche we do this yeah
yeah yeah and Tesla you gotta do it [ __ ]
off that's not just a scar right back
and then some guys take that hi some
guys put itself a little Drive and then
just spread their cheeks on the door and
go we ride bro that's never happened
ever auto drive list I'm gonna touch it
that's not true you see the rings of my
[ __ ] no but I got a great deal too
nope no I'm in Mad Max mode no hats and
I never happen to me so don't say that
no I'll just jump across and suck you
off that's never happened to me sir the
throat Tesla drivers do nothing wrong no
they don't
that's the drivers like we go like this
we go warriors of one before we do you
so speak to each other on the road guys
Madison tronic like sucking each other
off for the mohel hey guys we are carbon
footprints tiny not to make the car but
the driver
look at that car what a ridiculous car
and you see that and you go I want that
fin on the back of my car well no you
have to have that fender it's a race car
that's because it keeps it down but why
don't you since you're not a nice car
why don't you not have a fam you take
the fin off but all grill car guys would
be appalled they would appalled yes it's
it's you don't buy that car and take the
fin off we do door just get a cross
doesn't go quite as fast you can't get a
gt3 touring where the fins off now how
do you see out your rear view the little
challenging it is Right close think
those are brackets are in the way so you
know what guys do what what certain guys
do is buy brackets that make it even
higher so you cleared it say they are
from now I can't do that no this is this
is almost too much Thomas - yeah yeah
that is amazing does look sweet without
it now when you go to I wouldn't mind
taking it off and having it with that my
brother would be so disappointed
when you go to sell that which I never
well but carry he'll never sell I know
it's almost paid off we can oh boy were
you say though well like Josiah I was
gonna say you would you get your money
back oh yeah I make more than I paid for
right now on that thing yeah is that
really true yeah I'm Porsches yeah
really yeah I sir like that like Hermes
purses are that way see there's one
without the fin that looks sweet
mmm-hmm I prefer it without the fin I
really convergently like it holler at
your boy my brother's name is so mad I
like that that's it right there yeah I
think that's a good-looking put the fin
you like a little better that way huh me
I like that I love that duct fin I think
that looks sick bat right there yeah me
too I prefer that that seems a little
much can you go to go go to a 911 I kind
of want a Porsche badly but but I it's
just not your style it's not wants me in
romanette no I've always liked them I've
always liked the way they look and I
also know how good they are as cars like
I appreciate better car best car in the
road yeah now the ID was that's a
great-looking car right yeah there
that'd be dope for you dude that's the
new let's turn 17 there's now what is
that they all look the same and which
ones have fins which one I like that the
only ones I have fins are now are they
some GTS the turbos and then the gt3-r I
don't want I want one I want that green
one I wanna I wanna I want a cool 911
but not the crazy one I don't want to
spend crazy money just well do you not
you're not touching one of those around
120 grand but the thing is yeah but for
regular 911 brand new really
how about secondhand you just bought a
Tesla bro yeah I know but we were we
doing this
you're not kidding what it's like it's
just not for you dude it's not for me
what do you do after the show I didn't
do that when I saw you at the bar I was
delirious yeah I was at that I
understood dill there's yeah people were
talking me and it was like it was like a
lot of water yeah I'm saying the wrong
things to people like it's a summer ILC
Tuesday though it was like you were
staring at a white wall yeah you know
and I feel like in place was so
exhausted because when you shoot a
special so much is riding on it you want
it to be perfect I was telling chin this
like you know I I really shot you're
supposed to took the week off before you
were on vacation I thought yeah that's
weird I've never do that man and so I
lined up spots every single night of the
week last week leading up to it and I
did 17 podcasts I shot TV shows for
Showtime I did extra interviews extra
podcast I did Rogen's I did all this
stuff and by the time I got to Friday at
flappers I was like oh [ __ ] I have
nothing really my tank is on E
yeah that's why you want to recharge I'm
over I'm over saturated I'm over on
money I want to take a little time off
right I mean I took a nap and then got
it together for the show on Saturday but
I was I was running on fumes yeah man
it's just a learning curve that's all I
know that's all
I made the mistake my first special
which I pay I'm still paying for of
doing a movie like a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then this is after 10 years of working
on my spine my material and it was the
best material and I I went and did a
movie for six weeks and then did a week
and a half of shows and yeah whoo and I
had one shot
who's that had one show they didn't let
me do two shows oh one shot and I did it
for a show time I did an hour in 26
minutes and I'd never edit I didn't know
edit it and then I needed four months
I needed for x12 three months it needed
a little more time what do you mean
anyway it just gelled it well because I
had taken that six weeks off and oh
y'all you saving it for the material I
thought I'm saying you know they gave
you another four months no I needed it
for I need it for practice when I say
four months I need a month of just being
on the road yeah so I could have like in
the set figure out that's it Nick
just getting the order yeah and they did
it and I did it it was good but it
wasn't no it was this joint you can't
you couldn't do it I don't care who I
made big mr. Waite could do made huge it
didn't edit it down to an hour that was
it we want to take the whole hour in 26
minutes huge mistake he was watching
than that nobody you do it you do fifty
five minutes and I didn't because they
said don't worry about it I was like oh
okay here's the raw version of it really
bad idea just you make so many mistakes
and and I like hold well I was old
enough to know better
I've always been old enough to know
better yeah I hear ya
it's it's it's that I'd be like a
baseball player taking a month off doing
nothing and then trying to hit off the
best picture in the world and you're
like oh [ __ ] it's like also my problem
has always been paying attention to the
details and I've learned that as I've
gotten older but way too late you have
to pay attention to details will kill
you if you don't pay attention to the
details they will kill you you better
[ __ ] be if you want to be a like if
you looking people who are really
consistent and went a lot in a very like
someone like Rogan he's [ __ ]
detail-oriented
you better be you have to be you have to
be if we cuz they'll kill you just
another guy you just try another guy
that's right that his details were you
doing that's right I mean that's exactly
right I was thinking about just another
guy was thinking about how good Donald
Cerrone is when I was thinking about he
gets interesting greatly well do it he
takes these amazing fighters and these
guys are really good and he just makes
people look like just another guy I
don't I'm not saying her Nana's in the
world yeah but no but he's young and
he's hungry and he's powerful and you
know but did that but did you have him
winning that yep you take around yep
head kick Wow yep you called it yeah I
don't think they're everything yeah it's
not like a crazy call that's a good
fight for cowboy
yeah yeah and and I was gonna tell Boyd
and you think he'll get a shot of gin
tonic yeah yes I think yeah Connor take
the fight now you put your money where
are you - wait you know me I left Connor
think Cowboys my boy so I gotta wait
yeah the drought 55 you know judo judo
and Dillashaw will definitely fight at
35 yep
you still going with TJ yep me too me
too
I was crazy and then they watch some of
the back we saw some of the Pacquiao
Broner fight in the back kind of boring
yeah
nothing good Broner started crying about
the results afterwards nothing crazy
right this right sis we are you in town
this weekend yeah I think we knew if I
can pay him for a bait or fade or ooh
must be involved yeah of course yeah
I'll do them heartbeat my rap party is
well Saturday is my birthday oh [ __ ] I
forgot those Friday
no Saturday is my birthday so I'm gonna
there's a wrap party I have to go to
you're gonna wrap no now listen WRA P we
are rounding my show er your no no it's
a wrap party we're wrapping my show and
on the 26th at night also you can do if
I can be my commanding is when at night
at Hearst waste really
can I get in a little bit of it I think
what time we start I don't know left
that talk to Joe I'm coming anyway your
where's your wrap party I make an
appearance and I'll go to my lap wrap
party a little late what's your would
think somewhere in Hollywood not even
know but I'm you know I have to go gotta
go horse man yeah so he has a done
shooting the season of is this the wrap
party for school yeah that picture by
Photoshop Steve is so [ __ ] funny I'm
sorry but that's the time where we're a
little bit is so genius we get me for
god sakes that is hilarious dude that's
what we would look like oh how about
chin chin over there tuck up damn sister
in the middle of the show he got up in
peed no that wouldn't be newsworthy
though he pissed in his chair
out of respect into his buddy's mouth
not as not enough hold on out of respect
he didn't want to get up and leaving
cause you know and miss any of the show
so he pissed into a bottle a cup of cups
that they have there yeah a damn Samurai
so you pulled your dong out I had to and
you peed right there I was in panic man
I was freaking panicking so impressive
though did you fill the cup immediately
though it's hard to know because I knew
if I just let it all go it's just gonna
go crazy yeah so I had to just wriggle
it to a point where I was just got just
got out the initial first few I don't
know what do you call Alice's yeah and
then I just cut it off and I was like I
can wait till just to release it just so
I don't blow up just so I can go back to
the bathroom after that's over I
couldn't leave I knew if I walked up he
would probably recognize it's me leaving
yeah you know mess up his flow so I was
like [ __ ] I've done that I've done that
when I've been driving you said that
you're good at it yeah you said you're
the best
yeah I'm good chin also took a [ __ ] I
didn't take a [ __ ] though yeah everybody
in a bag but I did piss in my chair in a
cup I told you about this guy an actor
who was talking to me and this girl and
goes craziest thing you've done sexually
and I was like I haven't [ __ ] an
elevator and I don't know I [ __ ] that
girl out of my car and he's like come on
man like crazy and like what's crazy cuz
I don't know you ever hold a bag well
somebody take a [ __ ] in it oh no I
haven't I I don't really what did that
sexual oh my god that's I looked at her
like with new eyes I was like what are
you into bro freaking like he was like
not come on if you're her I was like no
definitely not
held a bag while somebody took a [ __ ] in
it a hard pass for me I would throw up
oh whoa yeah that's all know what I hey
man hey baby let me hold this bag will
you
dump oh dude let me hear you let me hear
you push I'll hurl everywhere let's hear
you push chin did you guys stay the
night no no the left right after the
hotel pen dreams dope yeah very nice
hotel you just the other night either
did you catch mmm I said well slept hard
and well I didn't fall asleep before I
am oh yeah
trouble sleeping we're talking my San
Diego everywhere you look we're sitting
there just a table full of like these
Brits who were probably like British
there SAS guy they they just looked like
one do
rougher than the next they had that sort
of like all the same exact body all look
like Navy SEALs no he's noticed all the
dudes I know it's the women to have the
hottest women everywhere they do have
this waitress at the pantry I was like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah it's stupid it's
stupid but I'm saying you were saying
you know we're getting to find San Diego
in a bar no just too many wrong I really
want to go out and thin you man there's
a lot of there's a lot of aggression is
what a male love drinking yet to the
male energy let a lot show energy yeah
the upendra is amazing yeah that's a
nice place
that's provision how about so the four
of us took scooters to the theater
jumped on birds and that's horrible and
they got done the whole access show I
heard that your boy Jason fell over the
handle [ __ ] and I wish they got that
on camera
I hate [ __ ] I'm not sure if they get him
and he broke the bird into five places
in here only had small he had just a
couple of like he didn't scratch his
skin up he's so they were laugh-in or
laughing yeah he's big I go how much do
you weigh he goes to 55 I guess he kind
of Haiti is like 250 I didn't see you
bust or much use out selling shirts or
never you'll never see Buster much
Buster is Buster does our merchant
buster
sometimes just be hiding that's him I'll
notice Buster like here come here cuz he
he he does I'm the one who sent you that
pornhub hat and I got a pornhub had in
the mail I was with my kids and I saw
that I threw it in them I threw it in
the trash like it was radioactive I went
ill and he I got that you send things me
I put a tiny picture of us in there so
you'd see I go well I didn't see the
tiny picture but that's very stalkerish
you think hilarious he's always in the
outside staring at everybody's I'll be
talking I'll saw a book and he's just
looking at me alright calculated he's
great so I like to show ya Buster's
great each other Buster's yeah Buster
Jason they're all great days it wants to
be a Jay Z J's has yeah chin yep yep
yeah we do we have an Asian operation
Asian operation do fighters amazing aka
Asian operation Asian operation that's a
very that's good though
I'm a fan yeah trustworthy or we got in
it's all over Asia we got Thai
we got lumps in guys we got Korean reah
we got Filipino we got a [ __ ] mixture
bro mm-hmm J wishes he was dead I think
we should have an Asians only policy
that's not a bad idea yeah just be super
exclusive about things that's a huge
area there are 48 countries in Asia but
you know you know I'm saying yeah you
know what I'm saying you get the idea
gotta be some Philippines Korea Japan
China Vietnam Vietnam that's pretty
inclusive that's pretty diverse good
buncha Cambodia Laos mm-hmm yeah well we
love our agents should we have some
current events sure sure we can do
current events all right cat so a man
who acquired an injury from lifting
weight and he thought that the best way
to cure this would to inject his semen
into himself once a month which got
infected so so by the way this is a this
is bro science cuz I remember when I was
doing Taekwondo us out there was this
idea that when you hold your semen
it goes up your spine and gives you
extra strength or did you do take one at
the special school did every as well
you're from Taekwondo this was like a
chromosomes was like when people like
studied back in the day and said kung-fu
meditation there'd be all these like
room there are bees like sort of like
myths that would go around that is an
old-school one yeah there's a super
old-school one yeah Jesus Christ yes it
goes up your spine what's complete
[ __ ] that's right so this guy what
this guy was jacking off into a syringe
act in his back basically he got super
sick mm-hmm
it didn't help it didn't help he went to
a doctor to get a check-up because it
clearly wasn't working the doctor asked
him what he was doing he told the doctor
the doctor basically told him you
shouldn't be doing that and he stopped
going to the doctor he's like yeah you
don't know what the [ __ ] he's done
yeah basically I heard
men's men's semen for women is a good
like moisturizer for soon have you heard
that I heard it I do know this
my wife was breastfeeding and we know
this kind of crunchy granola girls she
goes I have an eye infection do you mind
if I come over and get some breast milk
from your wife and you know my wife the
time was was pumping it you know and so
she got breast milk and she put it in
her eye because it's antibacterial I was
like she's gonna the [ __ ] I dog did
it help and get some [ __ ] drops I
don't know if it helped hopefully not
well no I heard yeah that bust my girl's
face is like the best moisturizer yeah I
heard it's good for their sons what I
heard dude yeah there's a girl who made
a YouTube video all about it oh really
yeah she talks about how she has a
friend who jacks off into a cup delivers
it to her and every morning she applies
it to her face how dare you not suck it
out of him that's the least we could do
no he maybe he's not attracted to him
she's dropping off loads every morning
she's a fuse she's bad does me she's a
[ __ ] she's just vain uh-huh you rub my
back I rub yours if I rub my back you
mean sucked my dick for this juice to
help your skin well in Geoffrey morning
what a great deal Jason looked at me and
said you know what I made your bridge
eight I made him eat fish semen secretly
because I personally they sell it and
Jay was like Jay goes like this Jake
it's so funny he just goes that's a
popular Japanese dish it is obscene yeah
yeah
why [ __ ] can I see that is do they try
another I never had that fish semen like
come on guys Kat real quick though just
to button this up the girl who lets that
guy bust in my cup and she puts on her
face that's on YouTube well that's I
mean that's just Scott viral
that's fishing I feel sick that does
look nasty though cuz I'll coagulate it
that's so [ __ ] disgusting I'll shout
the girl who looks like a bust on her
face though any funny I think I was like
you know what I don't need your head
to rub on your face let me do it I have
beer can I be honest with you yeah in my
years I've had and some girl no no
that's not what I did
okay now I've never really years you've
had somebody's based on your face no I
would run know what that makes sense
your face is aged well no have you ever
seen that that video that that porn
video where the cameraman is filming and
the guy goes Oh
get it off get it off get it off go find
I find that jizz yeah you too like get
it off get it off get off
it's bringing me on youporn no but I've
had girls guys go oh my god this I I do
this it's good for my fans of face
really yes I'm like alright this is so
funny
this cracked me out it's a real planted
goddamn what are you going into mount up
play that again why can't we have zine
hat hey I've ever seen when that dude
Berbers these parts like girl she asses
yeah typing that one June oh my god yeah
let me see that yeah that's my Lucy
other Monday here you have a bathroom
the one word they got guy farts and
girl's mouth on accident she's chill for
a reason she's looking at a sample you
asked I ran away by accident
nope just do that one there's gonna be a
bunch man fart on girl family no guy far
in her face there you go this one yeah
I fart on ghetto girl mouth I hate it
[Music]
all right that is beginners buddy on the
left be the Buddy Christ
this is such a weird business what a
weird business you know it's you can't
condemn it if you watch it it is what it
it's an interesting thing because you
have to admit that porn is damaging
right isn't it is it as if it's to the
people who do it right isn't it I don't
that's what they like to do but but I
mean that's a bit let's just say you you
kind of sabotage your future right
technically fighting is sabotaging you
yeah box inside a box in a film you know
those things are a skill that you get
paid a lot of money for food I secure
suck a dick but there's your words isn't
it not to some people not not to other
before our buddy who we all watch it or
we all have watched it yet we have this
judgment on it so as people are somewhat
ostracizes what they're kind of like you
know what it is so so porn stars aren't
invited into polite company a lot of
times they're judged
whereas boxers and athletes are they're
celebrated and stuff like that but but
it's it's this really interesting
collective hypocrisy that we have in as
human beings like we watch it but we
don't want it near everyone watches it
and I want them near me yeah yeah you do
bye man I've never I don't have a
problem with it I'm just saying I'm
cognizant of the fact that so here's my
question is it damaging because of how
society looks at it or is it damaging
because they do I think the only people
that I think it's damaging to people
that look at and take offense to us um
but maybe maybe the women that do it are
are usually damaged yes maybe I think
that guys are damaged too Yeah right
and what may we'll be careful we say
damn I agree why do you define damaged
because most fighters would be
considered damaged correct well that's
poverty have no other option bring this
up yeah it's a weird
it's a weird area to kind of like
delineate it's like interesting to me
yeah we all watch it yeah we all watch
it but they also say it's it's ruining
it for young kids so they watch that
they see how guys dominate the girls
stuff like I always had issues well but
here's the thing talk to a ton of girls
if you do a survey of girls a lot of
them like to be dumped naama same
hitting all that stuff and I'm seeing
they like a dominant man inside the
bedroom check the most part staff cop or
that's it certainly that's certainly
something that a segment of the female
turns them on into yeah it turns him on
why was fifty Shades of great such a hit
wrecked why is one the most successful
mobs long why were wise massive I were
hardware stores in New York running out
of the rope that he uses I mean so it's
it's something that they talked about
how about how that is a factor but but
but what I'm saying is that porn seems
to service all sides of human sexuality
which is a broad spectrum everybody
right and so if it provides a service
that we use that there's a reason it's a
multi multi-billion dollar industry yet
we all have this collective judgment on
it we just do you know so if you were
having a party and chances are and you
were friends with cup of porn girls or
yeah
chances are you you probably wouldn't
invite everyone right you would invite
them because other people would have a
judgment on it at the party or whatever
it would be it's just interesting it was
kind of a bummer
it's a bummer I always I don't I like to
think I died I'm not a hypocrite so if
I'm gonna watch it then I'm gonna treat
that person exactly the way bring a porn
star to your wrap party yeah yeah no
you're right
do you know I'm saying yeah I know
that's what I'm saying you wouldn't I
guess she's a wall of fire yeah you
would be I think it would be a good
ending off say Kara she has a [ __ ]
together yeah awesome she's great I love
us what else you got this one right here
so have you guys seen the Gillette
commercial that came out last week yes I
didn't see it I saw it like tell me what
you think
holy liturgy is this the best a man can
get is it
we can't hide fur it's been going on far
too long
we can't laugh at all
what I actually think she's making the
same old excuses but something finally
change and there will be no going back
because we we believe in the best in men
men need to hold other men accountable
come on to say the right thing to act
the right way some already are in ways
big and small that's cute
but some is not enough some who treat
each other
[Music]
because the boys watching today will be
the men of tomorrow
well not redheads what you take on that
uh yeah like I'm uh I'm a guy who puts
up the red flags like how dare you tell
that yeah you know but not next thing
I'm not anti it's a cool commercial
whatever but it's also boys boys can I
don't like that they they they're using
boys roughhousing as an example boys who
roughhouse boys are aggressive boys
playing rough sports they beat up on
each other they wrestle they fight
that's not the problem
no and and I and I and I and I that is
boys being that's why boys being boys
and and there is a bond when when it
comes to roughhousing and all that stuff
well sure so why is everyone up in arms
just because I think I think it's like
sort of the idea that you know there are
men who behave badly
but the majority on don't act correct
and I think that's why this is it's been
like Gillette you're trying to teach men
how to behave I'm all set I don't hold
on Julie you sell razors yeah you shut
the [ __ ] up I don't need life lessons
from the razor that's been a lot of the
reaction I'm not as I'm kind of on the
fence I'm mixed about it I'm like I get
it I get both sides I do it does annoy
me a little because I think I don't like
the examples they're using you so razors
you keep doing that and shut the [ __ ] up
there's there's that there is that too I
don't need you changing society with
your rage if they had left it at sexual
harassment when a girl walks by and you
go yeah baby and all that I get it
that's [ __ ] up seven easy never
happens all the time still I don't do
that never have done that but and I
understand that but I didn't like some
of the examples he used in there which
is boys roughhousing and just kind of
running so boys can't do that then you
wait boys are anti-war woman if they do
that ya know
or or or that like I don't agree with a
guy being a girl baby yeah but he not
only from the [ __ ] 70s you know West
Side Story what are you doing but if a
hot girl walks by and he just looks like
damn yeah are you not allowed to look
now there's a demonstrate look and
acknowledging that's an attractive
creature and then there's a big
difference between being uncomfortable
looking up and down and saying something
we can't look at each other anymore of
course you boys can't wrestle anymore of
course you can wait because I shave yeah
now now now he was looking like he was
about to deal he's just like well no no
no but he was about to do so so if a guy
were to go close distance and start
talking old on like hold on because a
trafficker watch plan he goes whoa oh
damn and goes it was hold on you are
gorgeous are you taking she goes yeah my
bat yeah can we not do that that's you
can so but the implication there is that
he was gonna go over and say some do it
he was gonna how would you believe me I
guess there was he was cat calling her
right that's kind of what the hottest
group of all time walks by me goes whoa
hold on I'm single you're single yeah
what's up girl were you headed right now
yeah I work here where do you work I
just meet people only online well I do
think that there's some of that busy
someone we're assuming that guy's gonna
grab my ass but women do deal with that
constantly right like a lot of times if
you're a hot girl you walk down the
street you're dealing with that [ __ ] for
sure and I bet that's horrible yeah I
bet this was a bad example yeah it's a
really good job they didn't do a good
job they they kind of her it feels
anti-male oh that's my process
and the black guys like whoa bro what
are you trying to do man I'm trying to
get her number to ask her to dinner yeah
we are you assuming I was gonna rape her
what's wrong with you
you're weird right what member Matt
Damon got got so much hate because he
said there's a difference between rape
and making a clumsy pass you know
something like that there's a we got to
make a distinction and he got so much on
he's like I'm [ __ ] stepping out of
this they'll a threatened a boycott his
movies so we've lost perspective and
we've lost the ability to good like take
God now yeah you guys gonna be super
scared yeah look at my friend here yeah
so I think Jillette got a lot of flack
for this you know it's just
all about women's rights you guys know
this I do not play that [ __ ] in the
least bit it's I dude I'm all about it
what I not about is anti-male that's
what I don't like right that all guys
are horrible that we can't have this
aggressive style that Mensch can't be
men anymore that boys don't roughhouse
you just ignored football needs to be
sorry what are what are you talking
about right I know some of the toughest
guys in the world defend women like no
other man why I always say to do with it
rapists have to be protected from other
criminals in jail
or they get [ __ ] even criminals even
men who steal and and kill they don't
like rapists so did this idea that we
come from rape culture is ridiculous
it's not true it's at the FBI stats are
hilarious you know that sat on one in
four women get raped that's that's a
[ __ ] stat that came up with us come
up with by a woman from Arizona who is
now a topologist she's a liar and that's
not true and the FBI stats if you look
at the Department of Justice FBI says
it's its way it's literally like in it's
like four or five percent so let's be
let's be honest with let's look at the
real data here mm-hmm doesn't mean it's
great doesn't mean it's acceptable but a
lot of this has been it's a little girl
on the thing going on strong executed
[ __ ] I'm oh yeah so this video has been
making its rounds in social media
they're a group of friends who like to
make music videos to songs where if you
muted the audio it doesn't match up so
this is one they're doing to Justin
Bieber
[Music]
it's Oh Larry oh my god this is
brilliant
this is Justin Bieber mm-hmm this is his
voice and they're acting like yeah he
can sing that kid dude this is amazing I
bet they have so much fun making these
Terrill they're just making fun of it or
what so if you heard of the mute like do
this you'd be like oh definitely a
hardcore rap song right
like actually that's great you know
they're mocking the rap game hilarious
[Laughter]
these guys are great it is awesome yeah
they do it to people like Justin Bieber
um a boy band called Big Time Rush stuff
like that do you think that let me see
the other ones dude these guys are
fantastic these this one surf squad this
one I saw this one's great have they
been out for a while maybe the past like
month or two is fairly new
[Laughter]
[Music]
the dead guy's hilarious she loves
working these guys are great it's really
well done - dude I bet they have so much
fun making these hits so out of place
it's great oh my god I love that they
learned the lyrics fantastic all right
what else we got a shout out to those
guys Jesus that's great father
yes Rihanna is suing her father because
he's using the name Fenty which is their
last name for a managing he started his
own managing company where he's using
her likeness for bookings and he
basically made millions of dollars off
of saying that she'll be at certain
events and use her for promotional stuff
when she has nothing associated with it
so does she not she doesn't get along
with him obvious no mm-hmm what did he
take off or something or what no I don't
think he took off she just found out
recently that something was up because
she was he promotional like photos of
her but it wouldn't be anything that she
has through her booking gigs and then
she found out that it's her dad and not
because he's her father he was able to
get away with awfully having a strange
relationship he's doing this unless he
had investors and they started using add
gold and he got duped that's all right
oh no lawsuit claims he made 15 million
it's not that's not a little money
that's good oh wait shoot yeah they
obviously hate each other so what may
seem extreme to file lawsuit against
their own bloodline Rihanna reportedly
sent multiple seasoned desist letters to
him but
was forced to take full legal action Wow
Jesus gross that's not cool sometimes
family sucks man Wow yeah what else you
got
so rapper quavo wanted to invite the
Clemson Tigers to his the QC
headquarters I'm not quite sure where
that is but he wants to invite them to
dinner to make up for the fact that hmm
you see headquarters think it might be
so he says I want to show Clemson Tigers
and POTUS how champs are supposed to be
treated you know welcome to come by the
QC occurs anytime dab and dab Oh still
go Dawgs that be sick oh and president
of these United States what I want to
show okay I'm gonna climb Center exam
because you know what happy right true
yes but that's a joke Mara we went to
the White House and they said that he
eats drunk food like he just eats hot
dogs and Hammer butt off but the biggest
problem too you know they do still nice
meals even though he eats fast food but
because the government's on strike the
chefs aren't in the white Oh gotcha
so he was like ah get fast food oh is
that what happened oh [ __ ] okay they're
the top the world chefs on guys you got
yeah that's interesting next one yeah so
there is dashcam footage of a car making
a slight turn the door opening and a
baby in an unsecured baby seat falls out
I saw this well [ __ ] thank God the
kids okay I don't know kid was protected
yeah like in the same job but dude child
seats save so many lives out into
traffic
here's ABC's Ariel Russia it's the
heart-stopping dashcam video capturing
that terrifying moment this gray car
comes around a curve look again the rear
driver's side oh he's open
mother of God still strapped in a car
seat mother of God you see her in the
brake lights to the hidden the brake
lights are on a green light horn several
times and tried to flag down the person
that lost the child out the back in
they just kept going just kept going
after hitting the brake lights knowing
she wasn't you know out of it or
anything but it's very calm very alert
police telling ABC News the child was
strapped into the car seat but the car
seat wasn't properly fastened inside the
vehicle experts say it's a common
problem one government study showing
nearly 75% of car seats are not you do
you know you can call any police are now
ready
California Highway Patrol an improperly
installed car seat
David was that
who's the dimepiece she's going I'll be
your baby I'm wearing diapers oops
what too much moisture eyes around her
face so Louie CK is back in the news for
a set that he did at the San Jose improv
you see I feel is he trying now this is
just his thing like he wants to he's
always been this coming now it's out
there right now he's always been there
once but he's always said [ __ ] that was
ages oh yeah so it's not surprising also
that's that's that I get that joke I
like to jerk off and I don't like being
alone
they probably cry probably crushed and
I'm sorry it's a good joke it's funny I
mean I'm gonna tell you me and Rogan
retirement when he decides just to go
out and start doing theaters they'll be
lies around the block use me kill sell
you know he's bigger than ever because
this is what happens right right when
when everyone goes when the people who
are this me to movement all those people
are so loud on Twitter social media try
to take away that everything that louis
ck's worked for and they go here's the
enemy [ __ ] this guy the rest of and
that's the majority the rest of the
united states and his fans and just conf
and general go you know what when i get
stand for this we're gonna support Louie
CK now you get this ain't fair what you
guys doing to here yeah he's paid for it
yeah
this isn't this [ __ ] up we're gonna
let you bully him what you guys trying
to do so guess what happens his ticket
sales go
that's right do the roof that's right
because your being out there an MPR MPR
they had these a National Public Radio
it's a very liberal place these people
who don't go to comedy clubs and who
were you know very sort of like very
judgmental and stuff and they were like
oh he'll never come back from this I
think I'll have to go to Europe and try
to scratch together a career I'm not
listening to this gon don't know guys
don't know what the [ __ ] you're talking
about
you just know they were so out of titled
regular people journalists the way you
people like us go what the [ __ ] that is
right these are liberal journalists
people like yeah you made some mistake
you didn't hit any women right no woman
beater you rape anybody
those are unforgivable actions yeah what
he did he paid for it yeah now he's a
comic like you he's been and we do make
this distinction and even when and you
know Americans are pretty forgiving like
for example you hit women and usually
you're in some big trouble but unless
you're gay I was gonna say like Greg
Hardy who was I think convicted wasn't
here or has had three different
situations that concern domestic
violence and you said Simon Singh when
he need when he need because you went
hard in the paint on this guy correct
super hard this morning on my show and
when he need what's his name in the in
the head
you went that's the equivalent of Mike
Tyson biting somebody's here it's a way
out he it was a way out cuz he got tired
and he didn't have the goods and he was
he was gonna start to lose he's a bad
guy bad guy who cares backup or
character pourable character can't can't
paint the zebra stripes zebra bad zebra
yeah bad till we try painting black yeah
and it should not gonna work he's a
zebra bat zebra just be zebra the
hilarious joke
yep so a nice short one somebody found
somebody found a clip of a Dunkin Donuts
worker part not partying but dancing
with one of his customers autism
customer met over a coffee order or
rather perhaps a colada and they bonded
over I'm not trying to be shitty at all
my planet which one works and which one
has this alright Brandon I knew you were
gonna say that it's the guy with autism
clearly the Asian that's right because
no one would dance that's what I'm
saying
what why what were you thinking I
thought that's what I was thinking
because they show them dancing both of
them have an interesting thumbs up now
now the asian guy has his thumb is doing
something downright strange and and
that's a hell of a curve to a thumb you
hit a large gentleman the answer is
we're all a little autistic so god bless
both up yep this poolman guys are sweet
man he touched me that he made my son so
happy oh that's awesome it was a legit
question I wasn't trying to make my
autism right how about this so Drake
wore a shirt with four teams you know
how there's a Drake curse if he like
yeah if he like he is a fan of your team
or if you're even Conor McGregor the
miners they lose step four back
following so he threw this up the Drake
curse good luck tomorrow if that's all
the team yeah that's obviously Photoshop
he's not really wearing that sweater
what I heard the house from his from his
story well I bet yeah I bet from a story
of it's Photoshop I bet he has a black
sweatshirt on the bow I see you're
saying so he did it's a post
gotcha that was a was a hell of a game
they were so good god that so you're you
know football well you would have to say
that the New England Patriots are not
only the best team ever would beat any
team in history but also Brady and
Belichick the greatest combination
without without doubt they'll be hazed
the greatest quarterback top
time's the best team
okay what's three they should have lost
yesterday but they'd still be Ford it
was an outside they were lost that game
here's some state capacitor fair or the
roughing the passer against brain when
they do the exact same thing in my home
the Chiefs gave them that game making
mistakes I think Chiefs are a better
team
I think Rams are better team you think
RAM I think Rams that we should beat
them
really yeah the defense good offensive
good I think they should win I can never
bet against the [ __ ] never England
ever never
brady solution it's such a [ __ ]
extreme winner you want to see one
that's a little controversial sure all
right so this is this video went viral a
while a while ago like in december so
did 728 j we're watching this you did
but no plate [ __ ] why saleh you watch
come on let me set the stage transgender
is in a store buying a video game behind
the desk is a young worker that sells
video games the transgender is a man
who's dressed as a woman and probably
have the full fun to go all the way like
yeah he wants to hit the video enjoy
excuse me it's ma'am
it is ma'am you need to settle down mind
your business
okay ma'am once again ma'am no you said
sir
once again it's man right before hand
you [ __ ] said sir [ __ ] take
it outside
boy call me cookie I'm gonna show you a
[ __ ] sir [ __ ]
like us just not all together there I
need your corporate numbers now for me
now you know the poor guy behind it
the poor guy behind them and he goes we
guys he goes guys you just know I mean
sorry sir
oh god I don't know over there so so
this this is not that this person is not
cycle I do you do there that guy's
you're dealing with a lot a way you're
dealing with a crazy person that's not a
transgender whatever I don't know what
the [ __ ] okay you can call it whatever
you want that person that human being
man woman kid with the long blonde hair
that's a crazy horse
oh so this is why it's current now so
she responded as to why she did that in
hit play well it's a funny newscast
you'll enjoy this newscast welcome out
there I will show you sir [ __ ]
the rest of it viral video it happened
right here in New Mexico it shows a
transgender woman losing her cool when
she says an employee at an Albuquerque
video game store called her sir I love
how the media video I love how the media
doesn't a million times on YouTube and
it's getting many just enjoy this a lot
of people have made fun of that woman
for her outbursts Thursday she did the
right thing by defending her gender
identity now only on four she's telling
her side of the story to Kai Porter
girls ma'am it is ma'am it's the video
seen by millions
Tiffany more a transgender woman who
recently started her transition yelling
at an employee inside this Albuquerque
GameStop Moore says the cashier
repeatedly called her what video game
was she by that's a good question or say
that Redemption game she bought for her
son for a guy behind the counter making
$6 an hour take it outside
we're going through
that sounds like we kinda sure now yeah
just now you're gonna fight your mister
so you're damaging property literally
five or six times
he probably sir it got me so human angry
I was causing that the Internet
responding to the viral clip which means
like Aquaman and Macho Man actually put
that there that's hilarious [ __ ] santa
larry auditory watch on ma'am but more a
local MC and rapper isn't letting the
memes get to work hold on viral famous
grace about the transgender community
plan this chin hold hi rapper we're
humans just like you people like you we
have parents we have brothers sisters
aunts uncles cousins we're just trying
to live you're on drugs yeah that's a
out here way that's that's [ __ ] she's
a rapper MC and a rapper that's him did
she start rapping no no but she's all
tatted up it's not a regular transgender
person because my actions were justified
i mean it was it was blatant and
malicious hey it was blatant and
malicious miss jenny ring
kai porter KO be my witness it's not
play it's like how the hell do you know
that's an easy person crazy that has not
to be transmitted it's just crazy or he
or whoever that is it doesn't matter i
don't give a [ __ ] I like how she how she
switched from female to dude I'll show
you my [ __ ] dude yeah I mean sure do
right now yeah that's it that that there
looks like there's a lot of math going
on and probably still and more looking
for attention and just not not clearly
by an odd world the video game that
person yeah I think that's more of a
mental illness oh it's probably not HUD
doesn't have a style and only she would
have I don't believe anything that
they're saying that person saying that Z
is saying Orser is saying or whatever
the [ __ ] I'll show you my bathroom
whatever ma'am I don't believe that them
I don't believe ma'am what else you got
yeah bad for her yeah it's rough I saw
this last week a mom saw her so this son
apparently overdosed on zan
since I'm very young he had a good
problem yes ooh man yeah and then their
security system it's called nest it gave
them out you have nest so I gave them a
little warning that some human being
like a person has entered the person was
spotted in your entryway and then that's
the actual image of that person holy
[ __ ] look at this how crazy is a vask
that's scary it's also she believes well
she believes it's her son probably helps
her deal with it definitely helps you
deal with it does but that's her system
so if anyone's hosting hoaxing it it's
her or her family members I hope I hope
I hope she believes that so hard well if
it is real it'd be [ __ ] nuts
I hope it is you do hope it is you to
hell
I guess so whatever brings her comfort
did you guys see the new Toyota Supra
yes you liked it on that you talked
about this weekend check out you should
get it I don't like it Jen you I hate
yeah I don't like it should be a lot
better Mazda Miata Mazda rx-7 2 million
dollars what the first one the very
first and production sold for 2 million
will be around 50,000 yeah for the
introduction so not about what were they
thinking well the kind there wasn't from
the side it's a fascist [ __ ] or supposed
to be all badass car performance a
pretty badass but we can do is buy a
chip like a single chip isn't that
expensive and gets like 700 or spy like
that the training everything is built on
is made for you to [ __ ] suit this bad
boy up I'm not crazy about it so yeah I
don't think it looks that great the 95
one still looks awesome Corvette yeah I
mean the the mock-ups are way faster if
you're gonna go that distance get a real
race car like a Porsche well they're
completely different class and it's a
fraction of the price these things are
that performance-wise are a monster yeah
this is how it should have looked yep
that's how it should have looked that's
a car yeah for the price though how much
it is
it's like 56 or sometimes a lot which is
in a 56 ain't bad man for that classic
car
but yeah I don't it just looks like a
Mazda Miata to me good Amazo me out of
sport new one Miata 90 2019 yep
you see the similarities between them
yeah I thought doesn't look like right
here especially right here they look
very similar [ __ ] are we doing those
cars suck on us
there's a lot of gay men they used to
drive mazda meows in the 90s
no it's just it was like there was there
was a fad actions we even did a thing
about it where a lot of gay men that
used to meet it Griffith Park you'd go
there where the gay men would hang out
like each other yep and it was just a
bunch of Mazda Miata is lined up so
funny Cooper's and Tesla's bro what
excuse me well that's the threes oh
those are the little ones right yeah
yeah Chris Hansen I didn't know he was
in debt he has some money issues so he
was arrested for bounced checks it's
just some deals show I know know what
wait hold on
he was arrested for bounced checks yeah
[ __ ] writing checks and bouncing gets
away with it
former hosts rest Monday cop said he
fought to pay a local vendor nearly
$13,000 for stuff he purchased John 15
allege he gave the guy around to bounce
checks and I guess he has a history
hundred fifty five bucks to a teacher 60
vinyl decals from a mom pops out of town
for marking months playing at 10:00 and
says that the kids were glare but Chris
bailed on the $13,000 tab yeah well you
know one didn't think he's right off the
sunset retire
I didn't think he's gonna predator
things gonna be that bad though see
that's the problem everyone thinks he's
on TV he's this millionaire and he just
has all this money in the bank except
for the rest of life nothing nothing he
needs a job you want Theo chauffeurs
Thanks so so so um he was what was he a
journalist or he was just a guy okay he
was a host of that show it was a hit
show though you remembered to catch
better so he was just a house host yeah
he wasn't a journalist or any of that
okay sure I catch predators bro
won't take you see he looks like a sad
man there that's so depressing to me
bouncing how is he 60 well has he done
anything since to catch Petter he kind
of got labeled as that dive we can only
do so much capture zones predators well
he's on Dateline NBC that yeah three get
started that's right so he is a
journalist yeah for sure let's we got
started and then that then the catch
better was a segment on there yeah and
then Hansen vs predator 2015 crime watch
daily that's what I see him on hold on
in January 2009 teen answers charters
larceny are the same thing well he was
married for thirty years that's not yet
eight Emmy Awards eight Emmys sell those
bro
I'm sure yeah so he should be doing well
right you should try lives in LA if you
work for Dateline and your money goes
quick yeah but money goes away you're
not you gotta work dude you know like
your Dateline tonight give me a fat
bonus into the year that right after the
subset and then he's also award-winning
I don't know it's a bummer yeah that's a
bummer another bummer
why don't worry son good-looking kid
he's good one kid right well he couldn't
get on a flight for some reason then he
said he had a bomb he's ready to
detonate it
smart kid dumbass and I was trying to
get on a flight but for some reason
wasn't allowed he became angry and
legend claimed it a bomb and his bag
which he which he dead night if he
wasn't let on the plane that's that's
when you're so far out there you thought
they were Mike I get on the plane was
actually spoiled rotten behavior and he
we're told to Harry shut up mouths
Antrim miles allegedly punched one of
the guards that's when police
interviewed entertain them issued cost
unite Coeur de métro accepting caution
England's essentially the same thing as
set their son for the fence like charge
the kind he got away with it big time oh
wow what a dumbass he's just a spoiled
kid
Wow
all right one other crazy one yeah a
woman in Indonesia I was taking care of
a crocodile uh I was trying to feed it
and then ended up getting killed by it
took her arm
they found her the next day with her arm
missing and a half of her abdomen
missing yeah they they roll yeah yeah
they that's a new ball look at the size
of that [ __ ] [ __ ] a pet crocodile did I
hurt yeah so she was in charge of taking
care of it it's apparently some Japanese
guys that he wasn't even there he just
owned it illegally and she was taking
care of it yeah see the video yeah but
they just moved the video of this I mean
just to the crocodile man ah [ __ ] there
do I get why are we killing this thing
no they're not killing baby moved it to
another place for now relocated yeah
holy [ __ ] that's a big croc no crocodile
killed her his name is Mary all right
pause that one scroll down look at that
sighs those things that's her yeah so
she's dead huh seven hundred kilogram
crocodile dude
so 1,400 pounds baby yeah the huge
[ __ ] crop that's it no no I mean
that's just other pictures only [ __ ]
what they do is they kill human beings
they keep they love eating junk alcohol
treatment rock house doing a crocodile
[ __ ] what else we got an amazing mob
kills nearly let me see
look at that thing that's just someone
walking out what was she doing she must
have like been throwing it [ __ ] like
hello does she fall in we have no idea
they don't give a [ __ ] up now they just
found her so I'm guessing the crocodile
Joe yeah she did Hearst that she slipped
just under she most likely probably
slipped and then he just grabbed her
grabbed her to do oh this is worse way
to go no you get caught and it just
starts to roll there goes but nothing
about the sheer panic fear inside your
body says you hit that one are you
thinking
shock just well no it's a it's oh this
woman jumped from tree to tree in
Australia and the croc came up and
grabbed her right in the crotch and she
goes this is it this is hacked and she
somehow stuck her finger in its eye and
grabbed on the Branson
let go and she found herself like on
that she was in a swamp and just waited
it out until somebody came to get her
hmm look at that thing like me and Jay
were talking we're talking about Tigers
there's something we saw some video of
this tiger I was thinking if you ran
that thing in the jungle and you'd say
come face-to-face with you just be like
dude like game over me later man and
it'd be the worst way to go that [ __ ] no
see I'd rather just snipe me out I don't
see it but imagine you see it standing
like oh [ __ ] dude here it comes just
like damn let's do it here he comes
let's do it I get low and I go come on
and I'd run right I go let's do it bump
it up it might be your only chance
yeah the tiger might be like oh [ __ ]
like if you run at it and you got your
eyes straight at it and you go come on
maybe until I think those cool oh yeah
or just it just hammer goes with it
tiger goes why I was just gonna bite the
back your neck kill you slowly now we
need to dick first
yeah that's do it amigo yeah Tigers
aren't really that afraid they they
what's the word they'll meet you halfway
oh my god yeah can you imagine fight you
they'll fight back the tiger well this
is that time I fed one and it did great
got low and growled at me and I was I
was like it was behind a cage I was so
afraid cuz yeah you're a male they don't
like male I was at Denver it was in the
Denver where iam Denver Zoo yeah Denver
quitting oh yeah and Delta and yeah he's
a she's well Sumatran tigers yeah the
vets are men and they poke them a lot so
they don't like the men they they're
fine with the females I was like well
you could've told me that cuz I'm now
I'm really afraid
terrible way to kill you just like yeah
would you guys do that thing where you
get tall you think you just
instinctively run yeah that would be for
a bear Tigers Tigers okay look he's
smaller and easier to kill tiger I would
I you literally if you saw him it was on
you wouldn't run cuz he tracked you down
so much faster
you'd have to [ __ ] fight yeah yeah
that's grab a stick and hopefully hit
him where he just goes around or try and
back up with a thick track hook he's a
Czech god
now your food bro your food what else
you got Jen alright this guy this dude
and his friends are banned from rural
Caribbean for life for jumping off it
was 11 stories that he jumped off a
cruise ship as friends though you know
you could die easily friends when
they're drunk - yeah they dared him it's
like my friends playing ping pong on a
cruise ship people call Flair's all
getting crazy [ __ ] playing ping pong
drunk they lost they picked the ping
pong table up and threw it right
overboard in the middle of the ocean
like well Wow welp wanna see him yeah
his friends will just hold our dick ulis
they look like the early 20s dude that's
11 stories look how long it takes
that's insane see that's not cool to me
I would never do it I wouldn't go dude
that was sick rave dude he's an idiot
this kid jump in - no no they just
replay sorry I know and I heard he said
he couldn't walk for like three days
because the impact
yes feet they're all bad for life how
they gonna figure it out who's this suck
dick you mean hotels on water yeah and
you stuck there and you got seasick -
cuz you get bad and you just have shitty
buffet food every night some Christmas
you know it's a hotel on water that's
right gödel correct either get on a boat
and sail around hang off the side or go
to hotel ya know don't combine him with
no thank you
um not anything crazy but this I found a
while ago this girl Oh doggy
do you know does she look familiar to
you at all hold on I gotta pee what says
yikes does that mean there's a date so
there's a not-safe-for-work type this is
on Barstow this is what
not-safe-for-work tabs usually do they
just cover like the very very tiniest
spots so it's safe for work okay that's
a girl that's a girl but does she look
familiar at all let's see there you go
another one there
mm strong real do they not her why she
blasts her [ __ ] in her face nor that
video
that's the girl on the horse yeah that's
on the horse oh my
hold on that's her with the big Houser
so she's lost weight know that this is
just a different picture model chose
that's her with those huge houses
they're real
Hauser's oh wow it serves good for her
the bikinis aggressive man leave a
little to my man and also the the also
get your contact of my face well the the
lips the lips have been way too done but
I can't tell us something blocking it
how can you see this it's kind of great
body yeah that is a fantastic body high
arch inner foot could be promising on
the road I don't know mmm-hmm but that
isn't it this is a war simple real fake
but the eyelashes are real um I would
take your first bin though we have to
you got to be courteous
I appreciate that bikini that is just
obscene and out stands that the last one
chin that's pretty much it okay good
luck piss them with a boner yeah that's
it that's it all right dude let's close
this thing be hard piss out guys I want
you to come see me at the end of this
month
January 31st Feb 1 feb 2015 17 me
West Palm Beach the week after that T
fact K for tickets give them this is the
fire kid we're out